[Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  in Hawaii we have a term kuleana which  means responsibility to be a Kumu hula  that's a huge kuleana  [Music]  the Hawaii people did not have a written  language and it was the hula that kept  all the stories alive and I take that  responsibility of perpetuating the hula  very very serious of the night you're  only dancing once all people say is hula  pastime is it a hobby the hula is our  bridge to the past the foundation of our  Hawaiian people it's my life  [Music]  60 women have to tell the same story so  we have to dance as one think is one our  souls need to be as one  there's a time in our history when hula  was forbidden that was a sad time in our  history  [Music]  but King Kalakaua said the hula is the  heartbeat of Hawaii people so where  there is Hawaiian people there needs to  be the hula  [Music]  you  [Music]